non youtube compte depuis ton aveux hier
qu'elle avoue arrive d'avoir des
sentiments pour moi j'ai ben ali et j'ai
dit l'adjudant chef du nord c'est là
qu'a dit que je mentais j'ose imaginer
que tu enfin libérée
sache que de toute façon c'est toujours
la première fois la tôlerie classique du
rock
[Rires]
donc voilà c'est la rose de l'amour
depuis hier elle signifie beaucoup de
choses ça a beaucoup parlé sur twitter
c'est pour toi c'était un grand pas aura
eu un avant et un après j'espère un
après cette heureuse prestance et à
grands pas non mais gaffe de ne pas
termine pas dans ta gueule
[Rires]
j'étais hors concours ce secteur
concours c'est bien pour ça que je
t'aime
[Applaudissements]